have you ever measured your penis before
yes I have and how were your results was
it fun mmm average I was comfortable
with my average-sized so around 5.15
then you know we'll find out later in
the video
so recently science has declared the
average penis size by measuring 15,000
penises around the world however at no
point did they ask us here at BuzzFeed
video to submit a penis measurement so
today I'm going to ask all my coworkers
the men how big their penises are so I
can come up with an average to compare
to the global average just to see how
does BuzzFeed video size up to the
global average of penis size so we're
gonna go find people and just ask them
some questions let's talk to Shane
everybody loves Shane have you ever
measured your penis I think I have I
haven't no you've never bet your penis I
think I have a long time ago it goes
around like six ish oh great and you're
not lying
I'm not lying Mason is not lying I
didn't measure the girth but I was
definitely above average in length great
have you ever measured it flaccid not an
animal have you ever measured it
stretched like grab the front of it and
just pull it as far as you can and mount
it nope would you we don't know
would you for science yeah of course
anything for science oh maybe if I give
you some time this weekend you could
come back Monday with just some results
for me for sure you're gonna get a hug
thanks hey curly because I'm looking for
a box like a good box that I could get
anonymous submissions in give a box I
could have we got our box we're gonna go
decorate it so that people feel really
interested in filling this box with
their submissions
so now we're going to open the box see
how many submissions we got hopefully we
have a big wide pool and we can check it
out so we're gonna open this guy up just
reach in here feels like a few couple
there this isn't a big enough pool at
all this is just three this isn't okay
hold on we're gonna figure out why guys
didn't do this hey Mike Mike hey did you
happen to measure and submit your penis
measurement what because I don't have a
ruler I totally forgot it's not
something I usually do okay okay Leo leo
hey did you happen to remember to
measure your penis and submit your
measurement I actually totally forgot
you totally forgot it's not a very high
sample size I used to be a scientist and
that's not good data right yeah Ned used
to be a scientist so that's fine I just
need to help people remember and provide
them all with the ruler and then I'm
just gonna bug everyone until they
measure their penis but I guess since
this is an office I should probably ask
our HR coordinator if this is in fact
okay so let's go talk to Melissa she's
gonna be surprised still like this I've
asked everybody here to anonymously
voluntarily measure their penis am i
legally allowed to bother everybody
about this I wouldn't Melissa wouldn't
but that's why it's my job to do it
great let's just go ahead and we'll just
go great and got to go ahead from HR
we're all good so I sat down at my
computer I did it I did a quick google
search trying to find some rulers they
were all too expensive to buy so I found
some printable rulers way easier and
just cost BuzzFeed money that I don't
even know where it comes from
so I printed out 30 copies of 12-inch
rulers and I'm gonna go hand them out to
those unfortunate souls who don't own
rulers themselves I've solved your
problem don't you worry now how do you
feel feel wonderful I can measure my
penis
I have no excuse now so I'm gonna hand
the rest of these out and tomorrow we'll
finally know how does BuzzFeed really
measure up to the global average I'm
gonna keep handing these out
hopefully tomorrow everybody turns them
in all right great so we're gonna open
up this box this is the last time this
is it however many ballots we have
that's what we have so we have 1 2 9 1
in my email 10 myself
11 11 different measurements to be added
together
that's an incredible pool first thing we
have to do of course fun math convert
some of the decimals back to fractions
it's to take forever
huh what exciting results my like what
does it have to say yeah we are on fire
what do you see what do you see we're
bigger bigger than you world
we're bigger than you world that's an
engine of 3rd 3rd longer yes we did holy
cow this is impressive bigger than
average bigger than average someone like
you know Holly like there were several
enormous numbers on that sheet wait
these are self-reported though right
their self-reported but don't worry
about it
all right and this this this helped me
feel good about my penis
right because you are you know I don't
want that I don't really good are you
worrying I mean that I'm in the
conversation I mean the bigger I'm
bigger I'm just I mean he's bigger he's
bigger some people didn't want to get in
that shot they're gonna even more upset
once they find out what the video is
about